this morning an update to the story of
Steve Dennett he is the Massachusetts
man who for years has been trying to
build his own 38-foot sailboat by hand
using wood cut down from his own yard
Brooke Silva Braga caught up with him
again this week as the boat the Arabella
finally reached the water
you can see what really what we've been
building wow
I mean it looks like a boat it looks
like a boat yeah and every stage of the
process that's what people say ah it
looks like a boat oh it finally looks
like a boat oh now it looks like a boat
when we first met him last fall Steve
Dennett had already been working on the
Arabella for nearly seven years so that
guy's a white oak he had started cutting
down trees on his family's property in
January 2016. he had no experience boat
building and no real source of funding
he had never in his life even sailed on
a boat and vowed he never would until it
was the boat he'd built himself when we
first started and I was like I'm gonna
cut down the trees and build a boat and
everyone's like you're crazy and then we
would talk to people who are in their
70s their 80s they would go to it you
have the stream go do it what are you
waiting for because why do you think the
difference in the generations I think
they understand what a lifetime is and
what you actually have the time for and
what you're going to look back on and
wish you had or hadn't done
so Dennett began to do it he says he
learned something new almost every day
like how to steam Oak boards down she
goes until they could be bent into their
new shape you have a matter of minutes
to get them bent into the boat before
they Harden and become non-playable
again but it quickly became clear he
would not be able to build a boat
himself for some reason there were just
too many others interested in helping
it's going to start coming down a little
bit okay Aaron Wayans did whatever
Dennett would let him he just finished
fourth grade I'll try my hardest
was supposed to be starting college but
came to where here instead that's it
this is a big step you dropped out of
school
I mean I def they won't let you defer I
hadn't started yet Dennis was able to
pay pauella and a few others once Acorn
to Arabella caught on on YouTube earning
ad money and crowdfunding donations from
supporters across the world and what's
everyone attracted to
is he gonna do it
he's totally gonna do it and I think at
first people were like I'm attracted to
watching this ship go down of pun
intended but now they're attracted to
like this wood came from those trees
and then it will float or would it last
Saturday more than a thousand people
dodged raindrops in mattapois at
Massachusetts to see the Arabella
finally touched the ocean
[Music]
it works well you're surprised then this
Tuesday seven years and five months
after the first tree fell the Arabella
and Steve were ready for the first sale
of their lives pilella and a few other
helpers got us out of the harbor Aaron
dropped a fishing line in the Atlantic
and Steve sat in the cockpit seemingly
overwhelmed these have to be big
feelings but you're not letting yourself
feel them yet oh I'm feeling them I just
I don't know
yeah I don't really have words
is this really truly the first day ever
doing this going out on the boat like
this yeah yeah yeah yeah you are filming
the first time of me ever at the tiller
oh come on you have to give me a better
how this feels answer then oh my you're
at the tiller literally for the first
time
come on it feels good share an emotion
it feels good pretty surreal pretty
surreal I believe that
one emotion Steve clearly felt was
gratitude
we've literally had almost every
demographic person you could think of
come through the shop at one point or
another the most staunch liberals the
most staunch Republicans
we've had gay people trans people
non-binary people people of color
we would not be here without the
contribution of all of those different
people and I think a lot of those people
that come they realize that you know
they got a lot more in common than they
thought yeah
why do you think people were connected
in this Pursuit when we're divided and
so many others
I think fulfilling and chasing a dream
is something that most people can relate
to I think most people have dreams I
think unfortunately a small
portion of people actually work on them
and are able to make them into reality
this is still just the middle of Dennis
dream now he and partner Robin Agricola
are preparing to sail across the world
just give pelella a year or two to teach
them how to do it yeah but we just need
to make sure we give that a good birth
exactly yeah this new chapter means the
end of the last one and that seemed to
be hitting Steve too sadness of not
working in the crew and The Boathouse
doesn't exist anymore and you know that
was
seven years of my life I went up
basically every day to go work in a
Boathouse
when The Boathouse came down and the
Arabella left his yard Dennis gave a
canoe and some of his tools to Aaron oh
boy this is going to be really useful
do you have any thoughts about what you
might make with them my rocket-powered
snowmobile
that sounds like a big project yeah
it's a fun one though
from the deck of the Arabella it sounded
possible
okay so look at the people out with the
sailboats and be like oh man that'd be
amazing and now I'm one of the ones out
there on Silva
for CBS Saturday morning Brook Silva
Braga off the coast Massachusetts
I feel like we need more of that in the
world hope
dreams following accomplishments coming
to inspiration yeah I mean and it's not
just the dream completed for him it is
it is the inspiration and when she talks
about I'm going to build my
rocket-powered snowmobile yeah go do it
exactly right a way to pay those dreams
forward yeah it's amazing